A Postmortem on the Ingen Incident
Hayley Denbraver
KATIE: Hello.
Come on in, sit down.
This is the last talk.
Whoo!
All right.
So, our final presenter of the evening.
I think we're all really gonna love her presentation.
It's Hayley Denbraver.
And she has been working as a consultant for
Ingen and she's going to talk to us about
what she's learned.
now, Hayley's fun facts, actually, are kind
of cool.
Yesterday she did the node bots workshop and
now says that she's completely and utterly
obsessed with building robots and wants to
go home a build and a robot.
Yeah.
She's got a competing thing, she's a knitter,
I was in the other room, I'm bummed I missed
it.
Has gotten her thinking about knitting.
She can't decide what she wants to do, build
a robot or just knit.
And I think she should just build a robot
that knits.
Yeah.
All right.
So, everyone, please give it up for our final
speaker of JSConf US 2019, Hayley Denbraver.
[ Applause ]
HAYLEY: All right.
Can you guys hear me?
Yeah.
Great.
So, evening.
We have a lot to get through.
And I need a sense of whether we have a quorum.
It does seem that the room is pretty full,
so I'm gonna say we do.
So, welcome to this meeting for the board
of the Ingen corporation held here at JSConf
US.
I have spoken to a few of you, but for others
who I haven't met yet, my name is Hayley Denbraver
and I've been hired to analyze the failures
that occurred during the incident at IslaNublar.
There is maybe uncertainty about the project
moving forward.
And that's why I'm here.
I was hired to review the recent incident
and to catalog the points of failure and to
suggest some next steps for the project.
So, I'm going to talk to you today there's
gonna be four parts, all right?
And first we're going to review the events
of the weekend so we can all be working from
the same set of facts.
Second, I'm going to dive into the flaws within
our design workflow.
Now, this isn't going to be about failures
within the code itself, but it's more about
our process and our practice of software engineering.
Third, we're going to discuss engineering
ethics.
And look into how ethical breaches compromised
this project.
And finally, I'm going to cover the idea of
chaos engineering.
And I'm going to suggest some steps that we
could take to build a more resilient Jurassic
Park.
I really want to be on the same page with
everyone with respect to the events of the
weekend.
So, we're gonna do a quick review now.
So, hands up.
Can you tell me if you've read the written
account of the failure at Jurassic Park?
All right.
I see a few hands.
That's good.
What about those who viewed the video footage?
Okay.
More.
That's good.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
So, that helps.
As those who are familiar with both can attest,
there are a number of discrepancies between
the two accounts, all right?
[ Laughter ]
And from my research, it's clear to me that
the video footage provides the most accurate
account so that's what we're gonna go with.
[ Laughter ]
First, let痴 meet our consultants.
Dr. Grant is a paleontologist.
And he works with his post doc, Dr. Sattler,
a paleo botanist.
Dr. Ian Malcolm has a Ph.D. in mathematics
and he's an expert in something called chaos
theory.
He details this as the idea that systems are
really complex.
And that they're likely to behave in unpredictable
ways, even when small changes or flaws are
introduced.
Recent staff members include John Hammond,
who is the creator of the park.
Dennis Nedry who was the lead software developer
for Jurassic Park.
Dr. Woo, the head scientist.
Robert Muldoon who was our game warden.
John Arnold who was our chief engineer and
Donald Gennaro who was our chief counsel.
All right.
So, now that we know the team, let's discuss
the events.
After a construction worker was killed in
an accident, Grant, Sattler and Malcolm were
brought to the park to render their professional
opinions.
Malcolm was aware of the nature of the park
and was against the project.
He was convinced that the park would never
work because of chaos theory and we're gonna
discuss that more later.
Grant and Sattler were unaware of the true
nature of the park.
They thought it was something more Akin to
a museum.
But they were initially surprised and delighted
by the dinosaurs.
While this visit was taking place, Dennis
Nedry was on site to take care of software
bugs.
We have since learned that he was unhappy
with the terms of his contract.
A while back he was approached by a competitor
who wanted to open a similar park and wasn't
above bribing Nedry to steal embryos to which
he agreed.
There was a significant storm while some of
our people were on a tour of the park.
A number of systems went down.
Some of the result of the storm.
And others because Nedry had purposely brought
them down in order to execute his plan.
Most notably, the electric fences went down.
Nedry died while trying to get the embryos
to his handler.
And was not able to look at the purposeful
software vulnerabilities that he had included
to execute his plan, or the multitude of software
bugs that were there anyway.
Grant discovered that some of the dinosaurs
had been breeding.
Even though this was supposed to be impossible.
Because we had made sure that all of the dinosaurs
are female.
Geneticist, Dr. Wu, used frog DNA to fill
in the holes in the genetic code and apparently
certain species of frogs can change sex when
in a single sex environment in order to continue
the species.
Or as Malcolm puts it, life finds a way.
While Grant and others were evading raptors,
Dr. Sattler with the help of Muldoon and Arnold
was able to manually reboot the power and
Hammond's granddaughter was able to get the
computer up and running again because she
knows UNIX.
[ Laughter ]
This success this success came at a high
cost because both Muldoon and Arnold were
lost in the effort.
And they weren't the only ones.
During this incident, we lost Nedry, Muldoon,
Arnold and Gennaro and we also lost the construction
worker previously.
There were also many, many close calls.
God, we have a lot of hiring to do.
Check the website, okay?
[ Laughter ]
The remaining team members with various injuries
and traumas were able to escape once the storm
had cleared and the T Rex and the velociraptors
were keeping each other busy and this brings
the relevant facts to a close.
Okay.
Now that we're on the same page, let's talk
about software engineering at Jurassic Park.
John Hammond claims that he spared no expense
in the creation of this park.
But this really isn't the case.
The resort is luxurious, and yes, genetic
engineering is pricey, but I determined through
my research that we dropped the ball when
it comes to software.
We're going to look at the pitfalls.
In this area, I am going to be nice to Nedry,
but I have harsh words for him later.
From the evidence I've gathered, it's hard
to believe this.
But it was clear that Nedry did not know that
he was writing software for a dinosaur park.
Instead, I discovered that the requirements
he had been given included vague instructions
like write software that will dispense food
at prerecorded times.
Write software to monitor a series of electric
fences.
Write software to visually scan the area and
report back.
Nedry eventually figured out what the software
was for.
And he had his suspicions confirmed by our
competitors.
But he should have been in from the first.
And if we didn't trust him to be in from the
first, then we should have hired someone else
even if that would have cost more.
Hammond was trying to be competitive by keeping
his plans under wraps.
But he was setting himself up for failure
by not giving his software development team
critical information.
In addition to not telling Nedry what the
software's for, an unrealistic timeline was
enforced.
There was scope creep, insufficient budgeting.
For instance, Nedry tried to get more money
to fix problems, but was threatened with retaliation.
And when the scope creep in the budget is
blown, how much testing do you think really
happens and what critical features do you
think are deemed "Good enough"?
Now, don't get me wrong, all code has bugs
and problems.
Everyone no one's perfect and everyone
has their fair share of flaws.
And a project can always be improved.
But not perfect code is a far cry from poorly
designed, poorly documented, untested code
running in a production environment that includes
velociraptors.
All right.
So, it's clear that we didn't approach how
the design of Jurassic Park in a way to best
ensure the success and safety of the project.
But I also want to discuss the breaches in
ethical practice that occurred because they're
undoubtedly a cause of the problem as well.
So, who here has heard of the Hippocratic
oath?
Lots of people.
Okay.
Good.
It's a pledge doctors give.
And it says to first, do no harm.
So, who here has heard of doctors, lawyers,
or engineers and when I say engineers here,
I mean like a structural engineer, a mechanical
engineer, someone who is licensed who here
has heard of someone like that either losing
their license or being fined or prosecuted
for unethical behavior.
That happens too.
The reason that happens is doctors and lawyers
and engineers are accountable for their professional
behavior in order to protect the people that
they serve.
Certain aspects of the design and conception
of Jurassic Park, and even specifically to
the software, it cost a lot of harmed to the
public.
And it should be viewed as a failing and unethical
practice.
Whether this means we'll be held into account
or not remains to be seen.
Nedry is clearly guilty of unethical behavior.
He introduced flaws into his system to exploit
for his own personal gain.
He accepted bribes to steal another's property.
He purposely wrote code so that it would be
difficult for someone else to debug it and
reboot it and expose his malfeasance.
What he did was illegal, immoral, unethical,
and directly led to the deaths of himself
and others.
And I think it would be easy to focus on Nedry.
And his short comings because he's a contractor.
And he's not part of our main org chart, right?
And he's also dead.
[ Laughter ]
But I can't let Ingen and its representatives
off the hook either.
If we think of breaches in engineering ethics
to only include things like sabotage and bribery,
we miss the larger picture.
Malcolm, our infuriating and unapologetic
consultant was right.
We thought about whether we could create this
park, and we never considered whether we should.
Malcolm was of the opinion that the park could
never be safe.
And while we could debate the merit of that
position, it's clear that the potential for
harm was much higher than originally portrayed
by some of our higher ups.
In the interest of financial gain, corners
were cut which resulted in decreased safety
and that's unacceptable.
Ethical breaches have consequences.
And in our case, it resulted in a handful
of deaths.
Some other injuries and traumas.
And financial loss to a number of parties.
And it could have been a lot worse.
I mentioned at the start that I have an interest
in engineering ethics.
And this is true.
And I could tell you that it comes from me
being just a really excellent person.
But that's not the case.
If I put my business hat on, I still care
about this stuff.
And the reason is that I'm interested in engineering
ethics because I am interested in resilient
software systems.
Ethical breaches have the capacity to compromise
a system.
And that's precisely what happened in this
case with respect to Nedry and with respect
to Ingen.
Ethical breaches are a source of chaos.
They are unexpected and their results are
unpredictable.
Training in and the application of engineering
ethics should never be considered what our
industry sometimes calls soft skills.
But rather they should be viewed as something
that has the capacity to make or break your
system.
My final point of discussion is about chaos
engineering.
As we've seen, Ingen system experienced a
high degree of chaos in the form of unethical
behavior, fraudulent system design and simple
bad luck.
The storm compounded problems, for instance.
If the board besides to move forward with
rebuilding and reinvesting in the park, I
believe that chaos engineering should be deployed
as part of the system.
But what is chaos engineering?
Well, chaos engineering is the practice of
breaking your system on purpose.
Observing how the failure propagates through
the system and documenting how the team was
able to respond to the problem and then refactoring
to fix that.
This is what happened on Isla Nublar, but
minus the on purpose part.
How do we approach this?
First recommendation, break things on purpose,
but don't start with production.
Break a Dev instance.
See what happens and how your team responds.
Release a hypothetical velociraptor before
you release a real one.
And that doesn't mean that you can't move
to prod eventually, but let's start with Dev.
Second recommendation is to start small and
iterate.
Break something small, make a prediction of
what will happen, see what actually does,
resolve the incident and then refactor to
prevent the propagation of the failure that
was observed.
Then break something else and repeat.
Train your staff on incident response so they're
not scrambling to figure out how to turn on
the generator or, say, how to reboot the electric
fence.
A final point to provide perspective.
Another term for chaos engineering is failure
injection.
It might be weird to think of something that
includes the word "Failure" as a positive
thing.
So, if that trips you up, I would say that
you should focus on the word" Injection" and
think of chaos engineering as a vaccine.
Whether it's dead or virus,software bug
is injected into a healthy system.
It addresses the issue and retains the ability
to address the problem when it's encountered
another time.
It becomes stronger by being exposed.
Upon reviews the events, it became very important
to me to talk both about engineer ethics and
about chaos.
I really think that these ideas reinforce
each other, especially for systems that are
critical.
It could be argued that we have an ethical
responsibility to build resilient systems,
especially when the human cost of failure
is high.
Additionally, the ethical practice of software
engineering, well, it removes an element of
chaos from the system.
Things may still go wrong.
But from mistake and not malice.
It's my opinion that any further progress
on Jurassic Park should go forward with these
two ideas as its base or it shouldn't go forward
at all.
So, how do we use these ideas to build a better
park?
I want to close my talk with the following
recommendations.
Recommendation one: Appropriately budget resources
to software design and testing.
Number two: Increase transparency between
stakeholders.
No surprises.
Three: Hire professionals you can trust.
Listen to them and make sure they have the
necessary resources.
And hire enough people.
Don't discount your staff.
Jurassic Park had initially been designed
to not require a lot of people.
But better software or automated software
doesn't negate your need for well trained,
capable staff.
Number four: To build a better park, use the
principles of chaos engineering to refine
your design well before there are actual velociraptors
running around.
And finally, number five.
Maybe just don't.
Yeah, maybe just don't.
As Malcolm puts it, this park might have been
doomed from the start.
The stakes are too high and nature is just
too complex.
Ask yourself whether you should, not just
whether you can.
All right.
So, it's time to call the question.
Who here on the board votes to restart and
reinvest in Jurassic Park?
I want to see a show of hands.
Yeah?
Okay.
And how many want to kill the project?
Show of hands?
Okay.
The lights are kind of strong.
So, I may be wrong here.
But I feel like the majority want to reinvest.
So so, the project is restarted.
And may God have mercy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
There's more.
Now, if you'll allow me a minute, I would
really like to address you as myself and not
in character.
So, thank you so much to the JSConf US team
for having me and my talk for this conference.
It was a real pleasure.
My real job, I don't actually work for Ingen,
is as a developer advocate at Snyk.
And I get feedback from Devs and learn about
the challenges that they face and to help
them out.
So, if you ever want to talk open source and
security, please don't hesitate to drop me
a line.
You can see my email onthis screen and
my Twitter handle is there too.
And I would love to hear from you.
I'll also be posting these slides at that
Twitter handle as soon as I can so you can
check that out if you're interested.
And I'll probably drop a link in the Slack
as well.
And if you're interested in learning more
about security, you can join a vendor neutral
security education focused group that I help
run called the secure developer.
We do virtual events and we have a Slack group.
And there's also a podcast that I think is
really good.
So, check that out if you're interested.
And I wanted to do one more thing.
And because I was so excited to give this
talk and because I'm a local and I didn't
have to drag a bunch of stuff through the
airport, we're gonna do some trivia.
And it includes some prizes for those that
get the answers right.
So, in 1993 I was in elementary school.
And we were ignored if we spoke without raising
our hands and being called on.
So, that's how I'm gonna operate here.
And you have been warned.
Additionally, this is 1993, so, you wouldn't
be able to Google stuff and you definitely
wouldn't have a phone that connects to the
Internet.
Play fair, all right?
So, our first question is: What had Dr. Grant
and Dr. Sattler discovered at their dig site
at the opening of the movie?
Any hands?
Front table.
Nope.
That's not it.
Red hat.
AUDIENCE: [ Away from microphone ]
HAYLEY: That is close enough.
It was a velociraptor fossil of a baby velociraptor.
Come get your prize.
It was an infant velociraptor fossil.
Yeah, you're welcome.
All right.
So, a retro fitted can of shaving cream is
used by Nedry oh, see, I don't pay attention
when people don't raise their hands and are
called on.
All right.
So, what brand is it?
Hands, please?
Um let's see.
A guy in the gray sweater.
In the middle.
Barbasol.
That's right.
Come claim your prize.
Yay!
All right.
This one I really like.
And I want to see hands, not yelling.
So, which of the following is a dinosaur?
Um let's see.
Let's go with the girl I think she's wearing
red.
Did you raise your hand tentatively?
Yeah.
Which one is a dinosaur?
Which one do you mean?
So, the the one that's flying?
Or which one?
The what?
AUDIENCE: [ Away from microphone ]
HAYLEY: The flying one.
No.
That is not a dinosaur.
Down front, here.
The penguin is a dinosaur.
No, really.
I read this in a book.
So the pterodactyl was a really good guess
and co existed with the dinosaurs, but it
was really a flying lizard.
Whereas the general scientific consensus right
now is that birds are not only related to
dinosaurs, but they're a branch of dinosaurs.
And so, people will sometimes call them avian
dinosaurs and they're still here today.
So, that's pretty cool.
So, come get your prize.
[ Applause ]
All right.
Yay.
So, we have our penguin.
All right.
And finally, the fictional island of Isla
Nublar is located off the coast of what country?
Let's see.
In the white shirt there.
AUDIENCE: [ Away from microphone ]
HAYLEY: Costa Rica, that's right.
Come claim your prize.
[ Applause ]
All right.
So, now it's over.
Thanks again to all the organizers and especially
for how inclusive and thoughtful they were
with things like captioning and childcare.
I had a really great time and I hope you did
too.
So, thank you so much, JSConf US.
[ Applause ]
KATIE: Thank you, Hayley.
How many of you guessed in advance and knew
what Ingen was and that it was from Jurassic
Park?
More than I thought.
I had no idea.
She had to tell me so I wouldn't ruin the
surprise.
Awesome.
What?
PARISS: She said she worked there.
Oh, it's fictional.